- I've actually talked to
some of the energy folks
from Massachusetts
point blank on this,
out of their state legislature.
And their goal is to
make Massachusetts
more energy renewable friendly
by importing renewable
energy from other states.
So my statement to them is,
so what you want us to do
is put up more wind
towers in our state
because you don't wanna have
wind towers in your state,
and then you stop using
these other forms of energy,
but make us cover our whole
landscape with wind towers
so you don't have
to look at them.
That's really what their plan
is, at the end of the day.
When I talk to them about
switching from, let's say,
home heating oil to burning
cleaner natural gas,
they'll say, well,
we're trying to just
get rid of all carbons
entirely, but in the meantime,
our plane is for decades
and decades and decades
to keep using home heating oil.
They're not really serious
about all these issues.
They're just trying to be
able to make everyone think
that they really are,
but look at what
they're really doing,
and that makes a big
difference there.
(bright music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is the junior senator
from the great state of
Oklahoma, James Lankford.
Senator Lankford, welcome
to The Rubin Report.
- Hey, very good to see you.
Good to be on with you
and have the conversation.
- I'm looking forward
to chatting with you
because I mentioned to you
right before we started
that we had your
Governor Kevin Stitt on
about a month and a half ago.
And I'm gonna start with
the same exact question
because I don't think people
know a lot about Oklahoma.
So if someone says
to you, what's going
on over in Oklahoma,
what do you tell 'em?
- Freedom and liberty,
that's what's happening
in Oklahoma, actually.
It's four million great people
who skip away from
tornadoes occasionally.
We get a bad rap for that,
but there's lots of
job opportunities,
there's lots of people
working that are there.
It's a really great community
and I have people that
I talk to all the time
that are from other places in
the country and they moved.
I will never move away because
of the people that are here.
And so it's a pretty
remarkable state.
It's a left coast
flyover territory
but we're glad they
just fly over us
'cause it's a great
place to be able to live.
- What kind of influx
are you guys getting
in these last two years?
You know, everyone talks about
all the Cali and New York
people going to Texas,
going to Florida,
going to Tennessee,
but you guys are getting
a pretty decent influx
as well, right?
- We are actually.
I talked to real estate
agents around Oklahoma
and I'll always ask them,
"Who are you selling
houses to right now?"
And they're telling me they're
selling houses to people
from Washington state, from
Oregon, from California,
from Minnesota, from
all these states
are moving into Oklahoma.
And my first comment to them
is, "Are you checking voter ID
with them before you
sell 'em my house?"
- Right.
- Which by the way, they
can't do, that's not legal.
But then the second
statement they make is,
oh no, these are the people
we want to be able to move.
They're fleeing from all of that
in those areas of the country
and they're coming to
a place that's more-
- Do you think people are
getting it because, you know,
there always is that concern.
I've told the story on
the show many times,
when I moved to
Florida last year
and I'll be walking my dog
and people would come up
and say, "Hi, oh you're
the new neighbor."
And they'd say,
"Where are you from?"
I'd say, "Cali", they'd
freak out for a second
and then, you know, I'd have
a Florida man shirt or hat
or I'd show a picture of me
and the governor or something
and then they're okay.
But the OGs there is
that concern, right?
That you guys have done
it right in Oklahoma
and you don't want
that mucked up.
- That's correct.
And again, we're open
to everybody coming.
All political persuasions.
People talk about Oklahoma
as a very red state.
All 77 counties
voted a Republican
the last three
presidential elections.
So we get that
reputation somewhat,
but we've got lots of people
and lots of diversity
of opinion on that.
And that's a good thing for us
to continue to be
able to drive that.
But we also wanna be able
to maintain the culture
that we have, of
freedom, of opportunity,
of business starts,
of low taxes.
I mean those are all things
that we want to continue
to be able to maintain
and protect in our state.
- And you guys must be
pretty proud of the policies
when it came to Covid and
not crushing the economy
and killing all the schools
and all of that stuff.
- Yep. Schools stayed
open, churches stayed open,
businesses stayed open.
And we had a few week
time period there
at the very beginning, in 2020,
where things were closed down
like the rest of the country
and then reopened
rapidly only to say,
hey, this is a terrible idea.
And got things back open again.
And it showed the
real difference there
in the way our
businesses bounced back.
- Are you shocked how different
the blue and red
states have become?
I mean obviously there's always
been a difference in policy
between Democrats
and Republicans,
but how the last couple years
have really unearthed something
that is causing people
to flee certain states and
go to certain other states
and it really doesn't
go the other way.
I'm guessing you're not
losing a lot of Oklahomans
who are on their way to Cali.
- No.
No, we don't have a lot of
Oklahomans that are packing up.
In fact, if you want to-
This is kind of the running joke
that people have in Oklahoma.
If you want to rent
a u-Haul truck,
a one-way rental to California,
you could almost
get that for free.
Because it's so cheap
to go towards California
with a one-way truck, but
if you're coming out of it,
it's really expensive to be
able to come the other way
because they're looking
for more people to-
So no, we're not surprised.
There are very few people
that leave Oklahoma,
they come to Oklahoma.
We're grateful to be able
to have great families.
We have a lot of veterans that,
as they serve at Tinker
Air Force Base or Fort Sill
or all kinds of places,
or Enid, around our state.
They'll serve there
and then 10 years later
they'll circle back to Oklahoma
and retire coming
back to Oklahoma
because they just love
the patriotic environment.
- I don't know if
you've seen the meme,
but there's a really
hilarious meme of Gavin Newsom
working at U-Haul, number
one U-Haul salesman
of the last three
years, I think.
- He is. He's a good exporter
of things California,
because people are
leaving his state, so.
- Yeah, exactly.
Can you talk a little bit
about just the economy
and what you guys are doing
on the energy side of things?
'Cause that's the type
of thing that I think
sort of translates to people
that don't live in Oklahoma
that are watching right now.
- Yeah. One of the
lowest unemployment
rates in the country
is in Oklahoma.
So we have very high
employment in our state.
We are an energy state,
but we are truly all
the above energy state.
People know us as an
oil and gas state,
but we do oil and gas.
We do a little bit of coal in
the eastern side of our state.
We have a lot of wind power.
Sing the song Oklahoma,
where the wind comes
sweeping down the plane.
We've taken that wind
and we've harnessed it
for power and electricity.
We use it not only in our state,
but we export it to
other states as well.
We have solar power,
we have hydroelectric in the
eastern part of our state.
We have geothermal.
We're an all the
above energy state.
And it's always funny to me,
I'll have some of my
liberal colleagues in DC
start lecturing me about oil
and gas and I'll say to them,
let's look up right now your
portfolio of energy usage
in your state and let's
compare it to mine.
I'd be glad to be able to
lay Oklahoma side by side
with Massachusetts for instance,
because we're using clean
natural gas to heat our homes.
Home heating oil
in their basement,
which might as well be
burning a lump of coal
in their basement, to be able
to heat their homes on it.
There's no comparison on it.
We're so much cleaner in
our energy development
than the northeast is, but yet
they're always the one trying
to be able to pile in
new requirements on us.
So we've already done
that in our state
and we're very proud to
have so many energy jobs
and such great energy diversity.
- So when you're
talking to a colleague,
let's say a senator
in Massachusetts,
maybe Elizabeth Warren, just
using her as an example,
and you say, hey, you know,
we're doing it right here
and we've got this
diversification of energy.
You guys don't have that yet.
You seem to want to
destroy the energy sector.
Do they respond? Are you able
to have that conversation?
Do they realize how
misguided the policies are?
- Well they don't like the
comparison side by side,
but I've actually talked
to some of the energy folks
from Massachusetts
point blank on this,
out of their state legislature.
And their goal is to
make Massachusetts
more energy renewable friendly
by importing renewable
energy from other states.
So my statement to them is,
so what you want us to do
is put up more wind
towers in our state
because you don't want to
have wind towers in your state
and then you stop using
these other forms of energy
but make us cover our whole
landscape with wind towers
so you don't have
to look at 'em.
That's really what their plan
is, at the end of the day.
When I talk to them
about switching from,
let's say, home heating oil to
burning cleaner natural gas,
they'll say, well, we're
trying to just get rid of
all carbons entirely, but
in the meantime our plan is
for decades and
decades and decades
to keep using home heating oil.
They're not really serious
about all these issues.
They're just trying to be
able to make everyone think
that they really are, but look
at what they're really doing
and that makes a big
difference there.
- What kind of tension do
you have as a state that has,
you know, you've
got the renewables,
you've got the traditional
energy sources, you know.
The federal government
obviously wants you to go
in one direction.
You don't wanna put
people outta work.
How do you manage all that?
- Well, a couple things in that.
We have a lot of
manufacturing in the state
'cause we have some of the
lowest electricity prices
in the country.
So we literally have
manufacturers moving to Oklahoma
for cheaper electricity
because we produce
so much electricity
from such a diverse
portfolio of it.
So that makes a big
difference on it.
The other parts are the
jobs that go with that
'cause we'll have a lot
of jobs that are created
in the energy market and in
manufacturing because of that.
That's why we have such
a low unemployment rate
in our state.
So it does make a difference
in our own economy.
- One of the things that I
talked to Governor Stitt about
that he was very fired up about,
really wanted to focus on, was
some of the tensions existing
around what's going on with
the Native American communities
and law disparity and
all of this stuff.
How is that all
shaking out right now
and your position
on all of that?
- So yeah, we've
got a pretty wide
diversity of opinion on that.
We have 4 million Oklahomans.
About 7% of our state
is Native American.
It's a very high percentage
for any other state on it.
We now have six tribes that
have a special allotment
from the Supreme Court
called the McGirt decision.
That McGirt decision said
that the federal government
has to be the one to actually
prosecute major crimes
in the state for those
particular tribes
and in those tribal areas.
It's not small and
a lot of people
across the country
may not track this.
They may see Indian
reservations in other states
where it's only tribal
members live in that area.
That's not so in Oklahoma.
Oklahoma we're very
integrated on it.
You would literally
drive through areas
and not have any idea
if this is tribal area
or non-tribal area.
Or you may have one house
that's a tribal member
and next door to them is
a non-tribal member on it.
Because of just our integration
of where we are as a state.
This is dramatically
shifted what's happening
in law enforcement in our state
where a police
officer doesn't know
whether they can
prosecute a crime
or there has to be the FBI
coming to be able to do it
and it's created quite
a bit of chaos and stir.
While the tribes are trying
to step up and do some things,
we have unequal justice
currently in our state
and this is something
that has to be resolved.
We're gonna have to
have a federal solution,
but it's gonna have to have
all of those tribes agree,
our state agree and
the federal delegation
to also be able to agree on this
to be able to get
some solutions.
In the meantime,
we'll have individuals
and we've already
had an occasion
where an individual
had multiple DUIs
but was let off
every single time
and then that same
person runs over
and murders a five-year old.
There's no way to
explain to some dad,
hey, it's because this
particular individual was tribal
and so they can get off with it
when a non-tribal member cannot.
That can't be so.
We've gotta be able to have
equal justice and process
and we've gotta have some
way for law enforcement
to be able to prosecute this.
So there's something that
came out of the Supreme Court
several years ago.
We're still working to be able
to get to resolution on this
and to keep working until
we get to resolution.
- Yeah. Are you trying to get
it back to the Supreme Court?
I'm actually not even sure
technically how that happens.
- So there's actually a case
that's already come back
to the Supreme Court
called the Castro-
It started with McGirt
and then it went back.
It was called
Castro-Huerta, second case.
And then it helped
define, for instance,
if a non-tribal member commits
a crime on a tribal member,
where does that go?
Does that go to the FBI or
does that go to the state?
The Supreme Court ruled
in the second case.
Well that one goes to the state.
So you can see the
chaos that's going on
in trying to be able to
prosecute through individuals.
Now you gotta know the
perpetrator of a crime
before you know who can actually
go through and investigate
and prosecute that crime.
But if you knew who
the perpetrator was,
you would've prevented the
crime in the first place on it.
So it's a very
difficult process.
So yes, it may go back
to the Supreme Court.
I'm doubtful that it will
fully, the Supreme Court.
What we've gotta do is
get a piece of legislation
through the federal
government, through Congress,
and have agreement
with the tribes,
agreement with the state,
and agreement with the
federal legislature
to be able to resolve
these differences
and try to figure out how to
be able to do prosecutions.
In the meantime, all of
our courts are overwhelmed.
I don't know if you track
all this, but federal courts
don't typically handle
murder cases, for instance.
That's a pretty rare thing
for a federal jurisdiction
to handle a murder case.
That's a state crime.
57% of all the federal
murder cases in the country
are in one small part
of southeast Oklahoma.
57% in the whole country
of the federal murder cases
are just in that
one small section.
That's not the
federal jurisdiction.
That's not what they
handle typically.
They don't have the
expertise to be able to do it
and they're overwhelmed with it.
And we've got occasions
where if a car is still-
- Right, just to
be clear though,
it's not because you have
a crazy amount of murders,
it's because of this decision.
- That's correct.
It's because the
federal government
typically doesn't have
that many murder cases.
So all that they have,
the vast majority of the
cases that they have at all,
are in Oklahoma because
of this McGirt decision.
And if they're prosecuting
those murder cases,
rightfully so, that also
means if someone stole a car
from a tribal member, no
one's prosecuting 'em.
And so now they're
just victims of crime
that no one's prosecuting
'cause no one has the
jurisdiction or the
time to go get it.
That can't be so.
This is why it's so important
that our state and our tribes
and the federal
government work together
to be able to resolve this
because we've gotta
have equal justice
for every single person.
We're not at at odds
with each other,
the tribes and the
state and individuals.
We're 4 million neighbors.
We've gotta just
figure this part out,
but it's a mess right now.
- Yeah, it really
sounds like it.
I mean equal protection
under the law.
It's one of the most am
American ideas that there is
and hopefully it works out.
Let me ask you a little bit
about just DC in general
and being a senator,
having to go to DC,
which is obviously
very, very different
than when you're back
home in Oklahoma.
The red wave didn't happen,
so you probably thought maybe
you were gonna, you know,
have a little more power.
The Republicans, at this point,
like what's the general state
of things in DC right now?
- Well right now, it's a mess
because of what's going on with
the appropriations process.
And you're right, we
all expected the red
wave would happen.
We hoped for that, prayed
for that, quite frankly.
That didn't happen
and we're still going
through all the process
of the whys and the
whats of all of that,
but that didn't happen
around the country.
So it's not just praying for
me a little more power on it.
It's a little bit of
sanity into the process.
You realize in the
Senate there's been
no oversight hearings
on immigration.
We've got 2 million people
illegally crossing the boarder
in the past year.
It's about to get even worse
and the senate's not
even holding hearings.
Like don't even look at
that, just ignore it.
That's crazy to be
able to have that.
And so we want to
be able to get that.
All the fiscal
sanity that we need
to be able to bring back
into the dialogue right now
of how we're gonna handle
the appropriations process,
which is in a
shambles right now.
Or even how we're
gonna handle spending.
Spending continues
to be able to go up.
Democrats don't want
to even discuss that,
have hearings on it,
to be able to talk long
term about entitlements.
What's gonna happen to be
able to stabilize our spending
or to get us back into
balance, no dialogue.
So for Republicans to come
back in the lead in the Senate
was really a shift in
leadership in the committees
and an opportunity to bring
some hearings up and to say,
let's talk about
debt and deficit,
let's talk about immigration,
how to be able to
solve these problems.
Let's talk about how we're
gonna handle complicated issues
that are currently being ignored
that are really important
to the American people,
like the economy,
and how we're gonna actually
bring down inflation.
But instead it's just move
along and ignore that.
That's the frustrating
part about that.
- Do you think that if the
Republicans had got the Senate
that they would've
actually accomplished
some of the things that
you're talking about?
I think one of the frustrations
that a lot of people have
that care about politics
and pay attention to this.
I think there's a
feeling sort of like,
certainly amongst my
audience and me personally,
like the Republicans
are obviously
way better than the Democrats.
The Democrats have
lost their mind,
but like you shouldn't expect
a lot from the Republicans
and they're probably
gonna let you down.
Do you think you guys
would've had a chance
to actually do some things
or do you think, you know,
the Republicans
do have Congress.
You think they're gonna
get some stuff done?
- Yeah, so there's a
couple things there.
If we'd have won
the Senate back,
one, we could have
controlled Biden's nominees.
He's putting in really
radical progressive nominees.
We have been able to
block a few of those,
but now they'll be no
way to block any of 'em.
He'll have 51 votes and he
will be able to rapidly move
all these nominations through.
So yes, we could have done
that and controlled that.
We could have managed
the different issues
that are coming up on hearings.
We still have to deal with
a Democrat White House.
And so just passing everything
and saying that we're
gonna get that passed
to Democrat White
House is not true.
But it gives us a
lot more leverage.
And if you wanna talk
about a big issue,
the 2017 tax policy
that happened
when we did the tax
cut in Jobs Act,
some of those areas
expire in 2026.
So in the next two years,
we're gonna be doing
major tax negotiations.
It would've made a world of
difference to have Republicans
as the lead negotiator
on that tax piece
than it's gonna be
to have Democrats as
the lead negotiators
on those tax areas.
So yes, I do think it would've
made a big difference.
But by the way, not all
Republicans think alike.
It's always funny, everybody
elects their Republican
from their state and
they'll say to me,
"Why doesn't everybody
function like you?"
And I'll say, because not
everyone lives in Oklahoma
and thinks like Oklahomans.
Not everyone's as
conservatives I am.
There are other states that
are not as conservative as ours
and we have a pretty
diverse opinion about that.
And republicans tend to be
able to not fly in formation.
They fly like eagles.
They don't fly in
formation all the time.
- It's like a bunch
of libertarians,
you get 'em around the table
and they argue about the
driver's license issue
for about three hours and then
everybody goes home angry.
I think that's pretty
much how it works.
I'm wondering, as a new
Floridian, I do see this place
that I'm in as sort of the
blueprint for a free America.
And I know that
Governor DeSantis,
actually just a few months
ago I was at an event
where he got a few-
about 10 governors together.
That's where I met Governor
Stitt for the first time.
Where they're starting to
coordinate a little bit more,
sort of outside of the
federal government.
And I wonder what you think
of that just conceptually
that the red states are kind
of starting to do some things
and not worrying always,
hey what does Biden
think about this
or the federal government
think about this?
- Yeah, they shouldn't have to.
Welcome to federalism.
That's how our system
was set up, actually.
Each state was supposed to
compete with the state next door
and we get better
in that competition.
We should be doing legislation
that other states look
at our state and go,
wow, that's really
good legislation.
We should do that in our state.
And so that competition
actually helps us.
For Republican governors
to be able to get together
and to be able to say,
what are you doing
that's actually helping your
employment, your tax policy.
What are you doing
that's being able to help
in different areas?
Great.
Continue that idea.
Our attorneys general have
done that for a long time
and that's been very effective
for attorneys general
across the nation,
to be able to swap ideas
and be able to file suits
against the federal government
to be able to push back
on that encroachment
in a way uniquely state
attorneys general can,
that I, as a senator,
can't file suit against
these different issues
like a state can.
And so when the states
cooperate together,
it makes a big difference.
And that's how our
system was set up.
- I ask basically all
my guests this question.
I wish I could get
more Democrats on
to ask them this question,
but they don't wanna show up.
We do ask.
What do you think has happened
to the Democrat party?
I mean this is not
the Democrat party.
I was a Democrat
for much of my life.
This is certainly not
the Democrat party of JFK
or of Daniel Patrick
Moynihan, Ed Koch, et cetera.
The sort of old-school,
blue dog liberal
that you probably had a decent
amount of them in Oklahoma.
It seems to be
gone at this point.
- Yeah, the party's so
dramatically shifted on this
and Oklahoma have
kind of a running joke
that I have with folks
to say President Reagan
got Democrats in Oklahoma
to vote Republican,
President Obama got
Democrats in Oklahoma
to re-register as a Republican.
'Cause there was such a
massive shift that's happened.
But if you go back
just 15 years ago,
every statewide elected official
in Oklahoma was a Democrat.
And that's 15 years ago.
It's not that long ago.
There's been this dramatic
shift that has occurred
in the National Democrat Party
and you feel it in
other ways in our states
with re-registration.
As people that have been
lifelong Democrats have said,
I don't even
recognize this party.
And they may be
shifting to independent
or they may be
shifting to Republican,
but they're shifting away
from Democrats to say,
I don't follow these
social policies,
I don't follow this
crazy spending policy,
I don't follow these
tax policies on it.
They look at the
different issues.
They look at, quite
frankly, the open border
and they say, I'm
not all in on that.
What in the world is that?
And so they just can't follow
where Democrats are going
and quite frankly,
DC Democrats continue
to be able to race each
other farther to the left
and there's this constant
push over and over again
to see who can out-left
the next person
and they're just racing away
from the American people.
- Yeah. Well my follow
up to that always is
do you think they believe it?
When you're talking to
your Democrat colleagues,
do you think that they believe
all of this stuff works?
That the big spending works,
that the giant government
programs work, et cetera?
Or is it that they're
just in the rat race now
and they can't turn back?
- It's a bit of both on that.
I do run into some
true believers
that are here in the Senate
and I also run into
some folks saying,
hey, I'll just get barbecued
if I don't go along with this,
but I'm not sure
this is a great idea.
So it just kind of depends
from person to person on it.
But there is a huge push
for them to continue
to go farther and
farther and farther left.
And I think it's the
remaking of the country.
It's this celebration
of, our country was evil
and its founding and
its history and its laws
and so we're gonna remake
the nation in our image,
into what we always wanted
it to be able to be.
But she's never been-
She's always been a
nation about individuals
having freedom altogether
and committed to each other.
And so, but that's not
where they're headed.
- Senator, I got
one more for you.
The one that I'm sure
you don't wanna answer.
Republicans are gonna
have to pick a president.
They're gonna have to all,
you know, follow somebody.
Obviously Trump has announced,
there's a feeling that
DeSantis will announce.
To me, there's actually a
pretty great crop of people,
I think.
Nikki Haley, Tim Scott.
Like there's really
a decent group there,
which you don't see that kind
of bench with the Democrats.
What do you see as the
future of all of this?
- I'm sorry, you're breaking up.
I can't hear you anymore.
(Dave laughs)
No, I'm kidding.
Yeah, the party's
gonna have to decide.
I mean honestly, you just
listed off a bunch of folks.
Mike Pence, Mike Pompeo,
they're also out there.
There's a whole big long
list of great Republicans
that are out there that
are good thought leaders
that the nation's gonna have
to be able to make a decision
on which way they're
gonna go on this.
And we'll see when the
primary's is actually begun.
Obviously, it's already begun.
President Trump has already
announced he's gonna run again.
By the time we get
into early next year,
we're really gonna
know the whole field.
If somebody's not
in by this summer,
they're not gonna
be able to get in.
But there are a lot
of folks that I think
were considering it
or looking at this
to try to figure out if
they can do the fundraising
and they can get out there and
be able to share the message.
I've said this publicly
so I'll say it to you
and to your audience.
Again, in Oklahoma,
when I talk to folks,
about half the folks that I
talked to that are Conservative
will say they love
President Trump,
they love the way he speaks,
they love his policies.
They want him to run again.
And about half the
folks will say to me,
I love President Trump
and his policies,
I don't like him as a messenger.
I wish there was someone
else that had those policies
that didn't have that way of
actually speaking and acting
and reacting to people.
So we're pretty divided
even as a state in Oklahoma.
It'll be interesting to be able
to see how many other states
are divided as well.
There's been very strong
support for the Trump policies
because we saw what he
did for immigration,
we saw what he did
for the economy.
We saw what he did for
our national standing
on the world stage.
So people are very grateful for
that, but they're divided on
whether they're gonna gonna
keep going on that again.
So again, we're gonna
solve that as Republicans
to be able to put
up our nominee.
What I want to have us do, is
to be able to win at the end
and to be able to articulate
what real Conservative
policies are.
And it's fascinating to me
the number of college students
that I talked to nowadays
that are young Conservatives
that will want to talk
to me about Ronald Reagan
and they're intrigued with a
Republican who won 49 states.
They're like, how
did that happen?
How did a Republican win
49 states in an election,
in his re-election even?
And to be able to get that.
And so they're fascinated
with that jovial, outgoing,
Conservative thought
that's winsome
and winning people over on that.
And I get that.
Culturally, we've gotta
be able to figure out
what direction we're gonna go.
But as a party, I
want to continue
to not just burn heretics,
I wanna make converts
because I think these
Conservative principles
actually do work and help
people in every race,
every community,
every background.
It really truly
does lift all boats.
And so let's go tell the message
and let's some messengers
out there go duke it out.
- Senator, I
appreciate your time.
I hope we can do it again.
Perhaps in person in
Oklahoma, because I do think
even though they call
'em flyover states,
they are important states
and that would be fun.
- You know, I actually
land in Oklahoma
so I know it's possible
to be able to land there
and not just fly over it.
And if we get there,
I can take you to some
really great barbecue places
and we can sit down
and have a great visit.
- Right on. Awesome.
Well I appreciate it and
thanks for your time.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our
politics playlists.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists.
All right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.